[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we can't be discussing Harry
Potter Lord Voldemort and the Deathly
Hallows in one of my previous videos are
discussed why Harry's expelliarmus beat
Voldemort Avada Kedavra during both the
battle in the graveyard as well as
during the Battle of Hogwarts but one
question that I still saw floating
around was why did Harry never feel pain
from Voldemort screw see artists curse
why was harry able to resist crucio an
unforgivable curse the following excerpt
from the Deathly Hallows depicts this
you see screeched Voldemort / the tumult
Harry Potter is dead by my hand and no
man alive can threaten me now watch
crucio Harry had been expecting it knew
his body would not be allowed to remain
unsullied on the forest floor it must be
subjected to humiliation to prove
Voldemort's victory he was lifted into
the air and it took all his
determination to remain limp yet the
pain he expected did not come the truth
is there are a number of reasons for why
Harry at this stage was nearly
invulnerable to Lord Voldemort and if we
look closely Mary wasn't the only one
that Voldemort spells had little effect
on Neville Longbottom was frozen on the
spot and in one swift fluid motion he
was able to break himself free from the
full-body pine curse that trapped him
fortunately there isn't answer to this
question and it's not just pot Armour it
was clearly thought out from the book
you won't be killing anyone else tonight
said Harry as they circled and stared
into each other's eyes
Green into red you won't be able to kill
any of them ever again don't you get it
I was ready to die to stop you from
hurting these people but you did not I
meant to and that's what did it
I've done what my mother did they're
protected from you haven't you noticed
how none of the spells you put on them
are binding you can't torture them you
can't touch them you don't learn from
your stakes it'll do you essentially
what happened was this remember Lily
sacrificed for Harry where she died and
made Harry and vulnerable to Lord
Voldemort well Harry actually made the
same kind of sacrifice that she made
just as Harry was protected by his
mother's sacrifice all of Harry's
friends and loved ones were protected by
Harry's sacrifice protecting everyone
that he loves against argue
the most powerful dark Wizard of all
time seems like a tall order
so it's untell along this protection
would have lasted but as far as the
Battle of Hogwarts was concerned most
was safe from that point onward that's
the first reason and it explains why
spells would have been ineffective
against people like Neville the next
reason once again comes back to the
Elder Wand from the book Harry saw the
Elder Wand fly high spinning through the
air towards the master it would not kill
who had come to take full possession of
it at last this passage explains that
because Harry is the more deserving and
rightful owner of the Elder Wand
that his power cannot be effectively
used against him in chapter 24 of the
same book Harry talks to Ollivander and
the following passage explains the
importance of the relationship between
the wand and the caster a person can
still use a wand that hasn't chosen them
though asked Harry oh yes if you are any
Wizards tool you will be able to channel
your magic through almost any instrument
the best results however must always
come where there's the strongest
affinity between wizard and wand his
connections are complex an initial
attraction and then a mutual quest for
experience the one loan from the wizard
the wizard from the wand what this
explains is there is more to being
powerful than just being a powerful
wizard utilizing a powerful wand the
relationship between the two is equally
as important as the inherent power of
each and a failure to establish this
almost symbiotic relationship will
result in a shortfall of magical
capabilities and the eventual failure
with one's mastery Voldemort was never
the true holder of the Elder Wand nor
was he able to form any sort of
relationship with it which resulted in
his inability to master it this meant
that his power was stunted and in an
interesting turn of events he was
perhaps even less powerful than he would
have been with his regular wand Harry
was the true master of the wand which
meant that it would not kill him and
Voldemort being the unlawful owner of
the wand could not produce a level of
power that was enough to kill Harry
killing curse or not the next reason for
Voldemort Cruciatus curse being
effective is that Voldemort performed
the curse on what he thought was a dead
corpse
you see screeched Voldemort over the
tumult Harry Potter is dead by my hand
and no man alive can threaten me now
watch crucio Voldemort cast the
Cruciatus curse to prove Harry's death
which means that he truthfully believed
that the Harry was dead in magical
theory it is clearly stated that one
must believe expect and feel for some
charms and spells to work it is my
belief that in addition to Harry
sacrifice the Cruciatus curse didn't
work because Volta
didn't expect it to he believed that
Harry was dead and wouldn't feel
anything therefore it didn't happen and
the last reason for the ineffectiveness
of Voldemort Cruciatus curse is that him
and Harry were basically one in the same
person at this point they were just too
interconnected when Harry went forward
to allow himself to die Dumbledore
explained to Harry why his soul survived
precisely said Dumbledore he took your
blood and rebuilt his living body with
it your blood in his veins Harry Lily's
protection inside both of you he
tethered you to life while he lives what
this meant is that Harry would live for
as long as Voldemort was alive as we
know Voldemort used a regeneration
potion to reconstruct his body one
ingredient of this potion was butter foe
which basically means that Voldemort
used Harry's blood to reconstruct his
body as who also would have been the
same blood that belonged to Lily Harry's
mother when reconstructing his body
Voldemort thought that this would work
to his advantage and that it would
shield him from her the same sacrificial
protection that destroyed him many years
prior he also thought this meant that he
would be able to properly attack Harry
what happened instead was that he
rendered Harry the only person capable
of killing him and turned himself into a
Horcrux of sorts for Harry
this meant that as long as he was alive
Harry could not die and for all the
reasons listed above Voltas Cruciatus
curse was ineffective on Harry and
that's it for this video you guys have
any comments or questions and let us
know down in the comment section below
until next time your or was it Harry
[Music]